this video is sponsored by endl
one
there is something deeply wrong with you
most likely lots of things
you almost certainly possess traits and
tendencies Central to who you are that
are unbelievably irritating to not only
you but also to everyone who knows you
everyone who ever has worse you're
likely not even aware of a lot of it and
you likely never will be not really
you'll never know how you really are
from the outside what it's really like
to experience you from the perspective
of somebody else whether it's a smell or
a tendency to interrupt or something
much worse the reasons for why certain
people have and why certain people will
distance from you leave you hate you are
often things you don't fully know and
perhaps can never fully know often
they're things you can never fully fix
two you will never be understood by
anyone there are so many things that no
one will ever know about you there will
be thoughts and desires secrets that you
take to the Grave with you out of choice
out of fear there will also be feelings
and experiences and perceptions that you
take to the Grave with you out of the
mere impossibility of ever communicating
them your whole experience of everything
what and how everything is for you
nothing else will ever know only one
thing can ever Traverse the same track
of time and space in the universe and
You Are Holy and forever alone on yours
forever alone in your head in your mind
in your red in your blue and your
sadness and your pleasure and in your
truth
three you will never fully know yourself
so much of us is hidden from ourselves
by ourselves what are the actual sources
of our thoughts our desires our fears
our dreams our actions the unconscious
mind is a solvent that all our
experiences and genetics are constantly
stirred in and dissolved away in two
we are the single solution where no
individual component is Ever Clear or
tangible to know what our Essence really
is as a whole the sum of all our parts
what we really want what we really
believe who we really are takes a
lifetime and a lifetime kills you
4. Nothing Is What It Seems
Consciousness has given us a front row
seat to the show of everything but it's
a magic show and the Illusions are
really good
five so much of life is Chance perhaps
all of it who you are what you think and
believe how much you have or don't have
how much you will or won't where you'll
end up everything is a product of where
and when you were born who you were born
to what brain and body you were born
with and all the things you have
encountered ever since who else can be
credited for anything other than the
odds Free Will and control are Illusions
we cling to to justify our pride
6. happiness will never come not in the
form most of us have been told it will
not in the form most of us are hoping it
will there will never be a time where
everything is finally perfect and
nothing ever hurts where the world is in
harmony free from chaos and tragedy
where we are at peace free from desire
and yearn life is mostly a cycle between
boredom and anxiety no amount of Fame
wealth control esteem family or friends
will ever solve that whatever is missing
it's missing in us the very condition of
our being
7. you will be replaced by others by
technology by progress the days when you
had to explain how things work to those
older than you will soon become the days
when you will need the explaining
perhaps those days are already here
soon the explaining will be futile at
some point you won't be important in the
ways you once were in the ways you once
longed and fought for
eight you will be forgotten you already
have been by past friends and colleagues
you will continue to be by everyone
eventually one by one memories of you
will shrivel up with the decaying minds
of those who once knew and loved you
along with them the last remaining
traces of you will wash away as if you
never even existed no matter who you are
the great enveloping Cosmic dark clears
the shores of all traces of past speech
goers
9. no real story ends well
Happy Endings exist solely to compensate
for the fact that in real life there are
none
things will go wrong things will remain
unresolved no one makes it out alive
nothing makes it out intact
10. in all likeliness when your story
ends it is the end
but your story hasn't ended yet and
despite all that was just mentioned you
don't want it to
despite it all we want to continue we
want to rebel against the absurdity of
it all to find meaning and Beauty in it
all
and we do
there's something in us so much stronger
than all of these truths and it is found
within each of them a poignant but vital
embodiment of the human Spirit the fact
that we can not only endure them but we
can invert them into Beauty and Triumph
if you know you will be forgotten you
can decide to live for right now while
you're still here if you will be
replaced then right now you are or at
some point you were important if you
know there is no end game no final piece
or success or happiness to strive for
then you can search for and find reason
and potency in all the stages of Life
along the way in the moments between
boredom and anxiety there's achievement
there's a sense of purpose there is fuel
to keep going there's opportunity for
Grace
if you know life is essentially luck if
you are watching or reading this right
now you can appreciate the likely good
amount you've had existing as a human in
the first place able to contemplate the
odds at all is perhaps one of the least
likely things to ever get a chance to do
in the universe
and while you're here even if you know
you'll never fully understand anything
including yourself you can know that
there is an ever-changing self and an
Ever Mysterious World to constantly
explore and delve into always capable of
surprising you of entertaining and
mystifying you a magic show of
everything from a unique seat in the
house reserved exclusively for you for
all of eternity
understandably the intensity of all this
breaks everyone to some degree how could
there not be something wrong with you
there is something wrong with everyone
but through unwavering honesty
expression support and effort we can
connect with each other over these very
truths
this video was sponsored by endel
understandably the complexness and
darkness in life can often be
overwhelming this overwhelm can manifest
in the form of stress anxiety rumination
difficulty sleeping and so on one tool
however that is incredibly powerful in
modulating and improving our state of
mind is audio but the audio we consume
is notoriously difficult to control
itself playlists on streaming platforms
or YouTube are often inconsistent
interrupted and rarely what our mind
actually needs endl is an app that
completely solves this problem by
providing personalized soundscapes that
are exactly what our mind needs when it
needs it using patented AI power
technology andal adapts to you and your
environment in real time inputs like
location weather heart rate and your
unique circadian rhythm are all utilized
to provide totally personalized
soundscape experiences that are the most
effective and relevant to you in those
late nights when all those thoughts that
you ignored during the day come back to
find you endle is the perfect Shield
using soft gentle sound pounds and will
helps calm and comfort the mind to sleep
andal's soundscapes are also great for
cutting through negative and distracting
thoughts during the day so to better
focus manage tasks and handle stress a
recent survey revealed that many endl
users have found success managing
symptoms like anxiety and Sleep
Disorders by using endl and according to
brainwave studies engineered soundscapes
that are personalized to individuals
provide the fastest and most consistent
Focus as opposed to playlists on
streaming platforms if you want to
better utilize the power of audio
yourself download endl using the link in
the description the first 100 people who
do will receive a free week of audio
experiences
and of course as always thank you so
much for watching in general and see you
next video
[Music]